[Music]
it is not possible julia i cannot
conceive how the idea of attending the
county ball can have entered your head
after what's happened poor young
hattersley's dreadful death suffices to
stop
that but aunt mr hattersley is no
relation of ours
no relation but you know that the poor
fellow would not have shot himself if it
had not been for you
oh and elizabeth how can you say so when
the verdict was that he committed
suicide when in an
unsound condition of mind how could i
help his blowing out his brains
when those brains were deranged julia do
not talk like this
if he did go off his head it was you who
upset him by first drawing him on
leading him to believe that you liked
him and then throwing him over so soon
as the honorable james lawler appeared
on the scene
consider what will people say if you go
to the assembly
what will they say if i do not go they
will immediately set it down to my
caring deeply for james hattersley
and they will think that there was some
sort of engagement
they are not likely to suppose that but
really julia you were for a while all
smiles and encouragement
tell me now did mr hattersley propose to
you
well yes he did and i refused him
and then he went and shot himself in
despair julia you cannot with any face
go to the ball
nobody knows that he proposed and
precisely because i do go
everyone will conclude that he did not
propose i do not wish it to be supposed
that he did
his family of course must have been
aware they will see your name among
those present at the assembly
and they are in too great trouble to
look at the paper to see who are at the
dance
his terrible death lies at your door how
can you have the heart julia
i don't see it of course i feel it i'm
awfully sorry and awfully sorry for his
father the admiral
i cannot set him up again i wish that
when i rejected him he had gone and done
as did joe pomeroy
marry one of his landlady's daughters
there julia is another of your
delinquencies you lured on young pomeroy
until he proposed
then you refused him and in a fit of
vexation and mortified vanity he married
a girl greatly beneath him in social
position
if the minaj proves a failure you will
have it on your conscience that you have
wrecked his life and perhaps hers as
well
[Music]
i cannot throw myself away as a charity
to save this man or that from doing a
foolish thing
what i complain of julia is that you
encouraged young mr pomeroy until mr
hattersley appeared
whom you thought more eligible and then
you tossed him aside
and you did precisely the same with
james hattersley as soon as you came to
know mr lawler
after all julia i'm not so sure that mr
pomeroy has not chosen the better part
the girl i dare say is simple fresh and
affectionate
your implication is not complimentary
and elizabeth
my dear i have no patience with the
young lady of the present day
who is shallow self-willed and
indifferent to the feelings and
happiness of others
who craves for excitement and pleasure
and desires nothing that is useful and
good
where now will you see a girl like
viola's sister who let concealment like
a worm in the bud
feed on her damask's cheek nowadays a
girl lays herself at the feet of a man
if she likes him
turns herself inside out to let him and
all the world read her heart
i have no relish to be like viola's
sister and have my story
a blank i never graveled at the feet of
joe pomeroy or james hattersley
no but you led each to consider himself
the favored one till he proposed
and then you refused him it was like
smiling at a man and then stabbing him
to the heart
well i don't want people to think that
james hattersley cared for me
i certainly never cared for him nor that
he proposed
so i shall go to the ball
julia demands was an orphan she had been
retained at school till she was 18
and then had been removed just at the
age when a girl begins to take an
interest in her studies
and not to regard them as drudgery on
her removal
she had cast away all that she had
acquired and had been plunged into the
whirl of society
then suddenly her father died she had
lost her mother some years before
and she went to live with her aunt miss
fleming julia had inherited a sum of
about 500 pounds a year
and would probably come in for a good
estate in funds as well on the death of
her aunt
she had been flattered as a girl at home
and at school as a beauty
and she certainly thought no small bones
of herself
miss fleming was an elderly lady with a
sharp tongue very outspoken
and very decided in her opinions but her
action was weak
and julia soon discovered that she could
bend the ant to do anything she willed
though she could not modify or alter her
opinions in the matter of joe pomeroy
and james hattersley
it was as miss fleming had said julia
had encouraged mr pomeroy and had only
cast him off because she thought better
of the suit of mr hattersley
son of an admiral of that name she had
seen a good deal of young hattersley had
given him every encouragement
had so entangled him that he was madly
in love with her
and then when she came to know the
honorable james lawler and saw that he
was fascinated
she rejected hattersley with the
consequences alluded to in the
conversation above given
julia was particularly anxious to be
present at the county ball
for she had already been booked by mr
lawler for several dances
and she was quite resolved to make an
attempt to bring him to a declaration
on the evening of the ball miss fleming
and julia entered the carriage
the aunt had given way as was her want
but under protest
for about 10 minutes neither spoke and
then miss fleming said
well you know my feelings about this
dance i do not approve
i distinctly disapprove i do not
consider you're going to the ball in
good taste
or as you would put it in good form poor
young hattersley
oh dear aunt do let us put young
hattersley aside he was buried with the
regular forms i suppose
yes julia then the rector accepted the
verdict of the jury at the inquest
why should not we a man who is unsound
in his mind is not responsible for his
actions
i suppose not much less than i who live
10 miles away
i do not say that you are responsible
for his death but for the condition of
mind that led him to do the dreadful
deed
really julia you were one of those into
whose head or heart only by surgical
operation
could the thought be introduced that you
could be in the wrong
a hypodermic syringe would be too weak
an instrument to affect such a radical
change in you
everyone else may be in the wrong but
you never
as for me i cannot get young hattersley
out of my head
and i retorted julia with asperity for
her aunt's words had stung her
i for my part do not give him a thought
she had hardly spoken the words before a
chill wind began to
pass around her she drew the shawl that
was over her bare shoulders closer about
her and said
auntie is the glass down on your side no
julia why do you ask
there's such a draft draft i do not feel
one perhaps the window on your side
hitches
indeed that is alright it is blowing
harder and is deadly cold
can one of the front panes be broken no
rogers would have told me had that been
the case besides i can see that they are
sound
the wind of which julia complained
swirled and whistled about her
it increased in force it plucked at her
shawl and slooted about her throat
it tore at the lace on her dress it
snatched at her hair
it wrenched it away from the pins the
combs that held it in place
one long tress was lashed across the
face of miss fleming
then the hair completely released eddied
up above the girl's head
and next moment was carried as a drift
before her blinding her
then a sudden explosion as though a gun
had been fired into her ear
and with a scream of terror she sank
back among the cushions
miss fleming in great alarm pulled the
check string and the carriage stopped
the footman descended from the box and
came to the side
the old lady drew down the window and
said oh phillips bring the lamp
something has happened to miss demand
the man obeyed and sent a flood of light
into the carriage
julia was lying back white and senseless
her hair was scattered over her face
neck and shoulders
the flowers that had been stuck in it
the pins that had fastened it in place
the pads that had given shape to the
convolutions lay strewn
some on her lap some in the rug at the
bottom of the carriage
phillips ordered the old lady in great
agitation tell rogers to turn the horses
and drive home at once
and run as fast as you can for dr crait
a few minutes after the carriage was
again in motion julia revived
her aunt was chafing her hand oh and she
said
are all the glasses broken broken what
glasses
those of the carriage with the explosion
explosion my dear
yes that gun which was discharged it
stunned me
were you hurt i heard no gun no
explosion
but i did it was as though a bullet had
been discharged into my brain
i wonder that i escaped who can have
fired at us
my dear no one fired i heard nothing i
know what it was
i had the same experience many years ago
i slept in a damp bed
and awoke stoned deaf in my right ear i
remained so for three weeks
but one night when i was at a ball and
was dancing all at once i heard a report
as of a pistol in my right ear
and immediately heard quite clearly
again it was wax
but in elizabeth i've not been deaf
you've not noticed that you were deaf
oh but look at my hair it was that wind
that blew it about
you're laboring under a delusion julia
there was no wind
but look feel how my hair is down that's
been done by the motion of the carriage
there are many ruts in the road they
reached home
and julia feeling sick frightened and
bewildered retired to bed
dr crait arrived said that she was
hysterical and ordered something to
soothe her nerves
julia was not convinced the explanation
offered by miss fleming did not satisfy
her
that she was a victim to hysteria she
did not in the least believe
neither her aunt nor the coachman nor
phillips had heard the discharge of a
gun
as to the rushing wind julia was
satisfied that she had experienced it
the lace was ripped as by a hand from
her dress
and the shawl was twisted about her
throat besides her hair had not been so
slightly arranged that the jolting of
the carriage would completely disarrange
it
she was vastly perplexed over what she
had undergone
she thought and thought but could get no
nearer to a solution of the mystery
next day as she was almost herself again
she rose and went about as usual
in the afternoon the honorable james
lawler called and asked after miss
fleming
the butler replied that his mistress was
out making calls but that miss demand
was at home
and he believed was on the terrace mr
lawler once asked to see her
he did not find julia in the parlor or
on the terrace but in a lower garden to
which she had descended to feed the
goldfish in the pond
oh miss demand said he i was so
disappointed not to see you at the ball
last night
i was very unwell i had a fainting fit
and could not go
it threw a damp on our spirits that is
to say on mine
i had you booked for several dances you
were able to give them to others
but that was not the same thing to me i
did an act of charity in self-denial
i danced instead with the ugly miss
bergens and with miss pounding
and that was like dragging about a sack
of potatoes i believe it would have been
a jolly evening but for that shocking
affair of young hattersley which kept
some of the better sword away
i mean those who knew the hattersleys of
course for me that didn't matter
we were not acquainted i never even
spoke with the fellow
you knew him i believe i heard some
people say so and that you had not come
because of him
the supper for a subscription ball was
not atrociously bad
what did they say of me oh if you will
know
that you did not attend the ball because
you liked him very much and were awfully
caught up
i what a shame that people should talk i
never care to rush for him
he was nice enough in his way not a
bounder but tolerable as young men go
mr lawler laughed i should not relish to
have such a qualified estimate made of
me
nor need you you are interesting he
became so only when he shot himself
it will be by this alone that he will be
remembered
but there's no smoke without fire did he
like you much
dear mr lawler i'm not a clairvoyant and
never was able to see into the brains or
hearts of people
least of all young men perhaps it's
fortunate for me that i cannot
one lady told me that he had proposed to
you who was that the potato sack
i will not give her name is there any
truth in it did he
no at the moment she spoke there sounded
in her ear a whistle of wind
and she felt a current like a cord of
ice creep round her throat
increasing in force and compression her
hat was blown off
and the next instant a detonation rang
through her head as though a gun had
been fired into her ear
she uttered a cry and sank upon the
ground james lawler was bewildered
his first impulse was to run to the
house for assistance then he considered
that he could not leave her lying on the
wet soil
and he stooped to razor in his arms and
to carry her within
in novels young men perform such a feat
without difficulty
but in fact they are not able to do it
especially when the girl is tall and big
boned
moreover one in a faint is dead weight
lawler staggered under his burden to the
steps
it was as much as he could perform to
carry her up to the terrace
and there he placed her on a seat
panting and with his muscles quivering
under the strain
he hastened to the drawing room rang the
bell and when the butler appeared he
gasped
mr mantas fainted you and i and the
footman must carry her within
she fainted last night in the carriage
said the butler
when julia came to her senses she was in
bed attended by the housekeeper and her
maid
a few moments later miss fleming arrived
oh and i've heard it again
heard what dear the discharge of a gun
it's nothing but wax said the old lady
i'll drop a little sweet oil into your
ear
and then have it syringed with warm
water i want to tell you something
in private miss fleming signed to the
servants to withdraw
aunt said the girl i must say something
this is the second time that this has
happened i'm sure it's significant
james lawler was with me in the sunken
garden and he began to speak about james
hattersley
you know it was when we were talking
about him last night that i heard that
awful noise
it was precisely as if a gun had been
discharged into my ear
i felt as if all the nerves and tissues
of my head were being torn
and all the bones of my skull shattered
just what mr hattersley must have
undergone when he pulled the trigger
it was in agony for a moment perhaps but
it felt as if it lasted an hour
mr lawler had asked me point blank if
james hattersley had proposed to me
and i said no i was perfectly justified
in so answering
because he had no right to ask me such a
question it was an impertinence on his
part
and i answered him shortly and sharply
with a negative
but actually james hattersley proposed
twice to me
he would not accept a first refusal but
came the next day bothering me again
and i was pretty curt with him he made
some remarks that were rude about how i
had treated him and which i will not
repeat
and as he left in a state of great
agitation he said
julia i vow that you shall not forget
this and you shall belong to no one but
me
alive or dead i considered this great
nonsense
and did not accord it another thought
but really these terrible annoyances
this wind and the bursts of noise do
seem to me to come from him
it is just as though he felt a malignant
delight in distressing me
now that he is dead i should like to
defy him
and i will do it if i can but i cannot
bear more of these experiences
they will kill me several days elapsed
mr lawler called repeatedly to inquire
but a week passed before julia
was sufficiently recovered to receive
him and then the visit was one of
courtesy and of sympathy
and the conversation turned upon her
health and on indifferent themes
but some few days later it was otherwise
she was in the conservatory alone pretty
much herself again
when mr lawler was announced physically
she had recovered or believed that she
had but her nerves had actually received
a severe shock
she had made up her mind that the
phenomena of the circling wind and the
explosion
were in some mysterious manner connected
with hattersley
she bitterly resented this but she was
in mortal terror of a recurrence
and she felt no compunction for her
treatment of the unfortunate young man
but rather a sense of deep resentment
against him if he were dead
why did he not lie quiet and cease from
vexing her
to be a martyr was to her no
gratification for hers was not a
martyrdom that provoked sympathy
and which would make her interesting she
had hitherto supposed that when a man
died there was an end of him
his condition was determined for good or
for ill but that a disembodied spirit
should hover about and make itself a
nuisance to the living
had never entered into her calculations
julia if i may be allowed so to call you
again mr lawler i brought you a bouquet
of flowers
will you accept them oh she said as he
handed the bunch to her
how kind of you at this time of year
they're so rare
and ant's gardner is so miserly that he
will spare me none for my room but some
miserable bits of geranium
it's too bad of you wasting your money
like this upon me
it's no waste if it affords you pleasure
it is a pleasure
i dearly love flowers to give you
pleasure
said mr lawler is the great object of my
life
if i could assure you happiness if you
would allow me to hope
to seize this opportunity now that we
are alone together
he drew near and caught her hand his
features were agitated
his lips trembled there was earnestness
in his eyes
at once a cold blast touched julia and
began to circle about her and to flutter
her hair
she trembled and drew back that
paralyzing experience was about to be
renewed
she turned deadly white and put her hand
to her right ear
oh james james she gasped do not pray do
not speak what you want to say or i
shall faint
it is coming on i'm not yet well enough
to hear it
write to me and i will answer for pity
sake do not speak it
then she sank upon a seat and at that
moment her aunt entered the conservatory
on the following day a note was put into
her hand containing a formal proposal
from the honorable james lawler
and by return of post julia answered
with an acceptance
there was no reason whatever why the
engagement should be long
and the only alternative mooted was
whether the wedding should take place
before lent or after easter
finally it was settled that it should be
celebrated on shrove tuesday
this left a short time for the necessary
preparations
miss fleming would have to go to town
with her niece concerning a true sew
and a trusseau is not turned out rapidly
any more than an armed cruiser
there is usually a certain period
allowed to young people who have become
engaged
to see much of each other to get better
acquainted with one another
to build their castles in the air and to
indulge in little passages of affection
vulgarly called spooning but in this
case the spooning had to be curtailed
and postponed
at the outset when alone with james
julia was nervous
she feared a recurrence of those
phenomena that so affected her
but although every now and then the wind
curled and soft about her
it was not violent nor was it chilling
and she came to regard it as a whale of
discomfort
moreover there was no recurrence of the
detonation and she fondly hoped that
with her marriage the vexation would
completely cease
in her heart was deep down a sense of
exaltation
she was defying james hattersley and
setting his prediction at naught
she was not in love with mr lawler she
liked him
in her cold manner and was not
insensible to the social advantage that
would be hers when she became the
honorable mrs lawler
the day of the wedding arrived happily
it was fine
blessed is the bride the sun shines on
said the cheery miss fleming and omen i
trust of a bright and unruffled life in
your new condition
all the neighborhood was present at the
church miss fleming had many friends
mr lawler had fewer present as he
belonged to a distant county
the church path had been laid with red
cloth the church decorated with flowers
and a choir was present to twitter the
voice that breathed over eden
the rector stood by the altar and two
cushions had been laid at the chancel
step
the rector was to be assisted by an
uncle of the bridegroom who was in holy
orders
the rector being old-fashioned had drawn
on pale gray kid gloves
first arrived the bridegroom with his
best man and stood in a nervous
condition
balancing himself first on one foot then
on the other
waiting observed by all eyes
next entered the procession of the bride
attended by her maids
to the wedding march in low hendren on a
wheezy organ
then julia and her intended took their
places at the chancel step
for the performance of the first portion
of the ceremony and the two clergy
descended to them from the altar
wilt thou have this woman to thy wedded
wife
i will wilt thou have this man to thy
wedded husband
i will i james take thee julia to my
wedded wife
to have and to hold and so on as the
words were being spoken a cold rush of
air passed over the clasped hands
numbing them
and began to creep around the bride and
to flutter her veil
she set her lips and knitted her brows
in a few minutes she would be beyond the
reach of these manifestations
when it came her turn to speak she began
firmly
i julia take thee james but as she
proceeded the wind became fierce
it raged about her it caught her veil on
one side and buffeted her cheek
it switched the veil about her throat as
though strangling her with a drift of
snow contracting into ice
but she persevered to the end then james
lawler produced the ring and was about
to place it on her finger with the
prescribed words
with this ring ivy wed when a report
rang in her ear
followed by a heaving of her skull as
though the bones were being burst
asunder
and she sank unconscious on the chancel
step
in the midst of profound commotion she
was raised and conveyed to the vestry
followed by james lawler trembling and
pale
he had slipped the ring back into his
waistcoat pocket
dr crait who was present hastened to
offer his professional assistance
in the vestry julia rested in a
glastonbury chair white and still
with her hands resting in her lap and to
the amazement of those present
it was seen that on the third finger of
her left hand was a leaden ring
rude and solid as though fashioned out
of a bullet
restoratives were applied but full a
quarter of an hour elapsed before julia
opened her eyes
and a little color returned to her lips
and cheeks but as she raised her hands
to her brow to wipe away the damp that
had formed on it
her eye caught sight of the lead and
ring and with a cry of horror she sank
again into insensibility
the congregation slowly left the church
awestruck whispering asking questions
receiving no satisfactory answers
forming surmises
all incorrect i'm very much afraid mr
lawler said the rector
that it will be impossible to proceed
with the service today it must be
postponed till ms demand is in a
condition to conclude her part
and assign the register i do not see how
it can be gone on with today
she's quite unequal to the effort the
carriage which was to have conveyed the
couple to miss fleming's house
and then later to have taken them to the
station for their honeymoon the horses
decorated with white rosettes
the whip adorned with a white bow had
now to convey julia
hardly conscious supported by her aunt
to her home
no rice could be thrown the bell ringers
prepared to give a joyous peel
were constrained to depart the reception
at miss flemings was postponed
no one thought of attending the cakes
the ices
were consumed in the kitchen the
bridegroom
bewildered almost frantic ran hither and
thither not knowing what to do
what to say julia lay as a stone for
fully two
hours and when she came to herself she
could not speak
when conscious she raised her left hand
looked on the lead and ring
and sank back again into senselessness
not till late in the evening was she
sufficiently recovered to speak
and then she begged her aunt who would
remain by her bed without stirring
to dismiss the attendance she desired to
speak with her alone
when no one was in the room with her
save miss fleming she said in a whisper
oh and elizabeth oh auntie such an awful
thing has happened
i can never marry mr lawler never
i've married james hattersley i am a
dead man's wife
at the time that james lawler was making
the responses i heard a piping voice in
my ear
an unearthly voice saying the same words
when i said i julia take you james to my
wedded husband
you know mr hattersley is james as well
as mr lawler
than the words applied to him as much or
as well as to the other
and then when it came to the giving of
the ring there was the explosion in my
ear as before
and the lead and ring was forced onto my
finger and not james lawler's golden
ring
it is of no use my resisting anymore i
am a dead man's wife
and i cannot marry james lawler
some years have elapsed since that
disastrous day
and that incomplete marriage miss demand
is miss demand still
and she has never been able to remove
the lead and ring from the third finger
of her left hand
whenever the attempt has been made
either to disengage it by drawing it off
or by cutting through it
there has ensued that terrifying
discharge as of a gun into her ear
causing insensibility the prostration
that has followed
the terror it has inspired have so
affected her nerves
that she has desisted from every attempt
to rid herself of the ring
she invariably wears a glove on her left
hand and it is bulged over the third
finger
where lies that lead and ring she is not
a happy woman
although her aunt is dead and has left
her a handsome estate
she has not got many acquaintances she
has no friends
for her temper is unamenable and her
tongue is bitter
she supposes that the world as far as
she knows it is in league against her
towards the memory of james hattersley
she entertains a deadly hate if an
incantation could lay his spirit
if prayer could give him repose she
would have recourse to none of these
expedients
even though they might relieve her so
bitter is her resentment
and she harbors a silent against
providence for allowing the dead to walk
to molest the living
church peril is a house so beset and
frequented by specters
both visible and audible that none of
the family which it shelters under its
acre and a half of green copper roofs
take psychical phenomena with any
seriousness for to the peverels the
appearance of a ghost is a matter of
hardly greater significance
than is the appearance of the post to
those who live in more ordinary houses
it arrives that is to say practically
every day it knocks or makes other
noises
it is observed coming up the drive or in
other places
i myself when staying there have seen
the present mrs peverell who was rather
short-sighted
peer into the dusk while we were taking
our coffee on the terrace after dinner
and say to her daughter my dear was that
not the blue lady who's just gone into
the shrubbery
i hope she doesn't frighten flow whistle
for flow dear
flo it may be remarked is the youngest
and most precious of many datsuns
blanche peverell gave a cursory whistle
and crunched the sugar left unmelted at
the bottom of her coffee cup
between her very white teeth oh darling
flo isn't so silly as to mind she said
poor blue aunt barbara is such a bore
whenever i meet her she always looks as
if she wanted to speak to me
but when i say what is it aunt barbara
she never utters but only points
somewhere toward the house which is so
vague
i believe there was something she wanted
to confess about 200 years ago but she's
forgotten what it is
here flo gave two or three short pleased
barks and came out of the shrubbery
wagging her tail
and capering round what appeared to me
to be a perfectly empty space on the
lawn
there flo has made friends with her said
mrs peverle i wonder why she dresses in
that very stupid shade of blue
from this it may be gathered that even
with regard to psychical phenomena there
is some truth in the proverb that speaks
of familiarity
but the peverals do not exactly treat
their ghosts with contempt
since most of that delightful family
never despised anybody
except such people as avowedly did not
care for hunting or shooting or gall for
skating
and as all of their ghosts are of their
family it seems reasonable to suppose
that they all
even the poor blue lady excelled at one
time in fieldsports
so far then they harbor no such
unkindness or contempt but only pity
of one peverell indeed who broke his
neck in vainly attempting to ride up the
main staircase on a thoroughbred mare
after some monstrous and violent deed in
the back garden they are very fond
and blanche comes downstairs in the
morning with an eye unusually bright
when she can announce that master
anthony was very loud last night
he apart from the fact of his having
been so foul or ruffian
was a tremendous fellow across country
and they like these indications of the
continuance of his superb vitality
in fact it is supposed to be a
compliment when you go to stay at church
peverell
to be assigned a bedroom which is
frequented by defunct members of the
family
it means that you are worthy to look on
the august and villainous dead
and you will find yourself shown into
some vaulted or tapestry chamber
without benefit of electric light and
you are told that great-great-grandma
bridget occasionally has vague business
by the fireplace
but it is better not to talk to her and
that you will hear master anthony
awfully well if he attempts the front
staircase any time before morning
there you are left for your night's
repose and having quakingly undressed
begin reluctantly to put out your
candles it is drafty in these great
chambers
and the solemn tapestry swings and
bellows and subsides
and the fire light dances on the forms
of huntsmen and warriors and stern
pursuits
then you climb into your bed a bed so
huge that you feel as if the desert of
sahara was spread for you
and pray like the mariners who sailed
with saint paul for day
and all the time you were aware that
freddie and harry and blanche and
possibly even mrs peverell
are quite capable of dressing up and
making disquieting tappings outside your
door
so that when you open it some
inconjecturable horror fronts you
for myself i stick steadily to the
assertion that i have an obscure
valvular disease
of the heart and so sleep undisturbed in
the new wing of the house
where aunt barbara and
great-great-grandmama bridget and master
anthony never penetrate
i forget the details of
great-great-grandmama bridget but she
certainly cut the throat of some distant
relation
before she disemboweled herself with the
axe that had been used at agincourt
before that she had led a very sultry
life crammed with amazing incident
but there is one ghost at church
peverell at which the family never laugh
in which they feel no
friendly and amused interest and of
which they only speak
just as much as is necessary for the
safety of their guests
more properly it should be described as
two ghosts for the haunt in question is
that of two very young children who were
twins these not without reason the
family take very seriously indeed
the story of them as told to me by mrs
peverell is as follows
in the year 1602 the same being the last
of queen elizabeth's reign
a certain dick peverell was greatly in
favor at court
he was brother to master joseph peverell
then owner of the family house and lands
who two years previously at the
respectable age of 74
became father of twin boys first born of
his progeny
it is known that the royal and ancient
virgin had said to handsome dick
who was nearly 40 years his brother's
junior it's a pity that you are not
master of church peverell
and these words probably suggested to
him a sinister design
be that as it may handsome dick who very
adequately sustained the family
reputation for wickedness
set off to ride down to yorkshire and
found that very conveniently
his brother joseph had just been seized
with an apoplexy which appeared to be
the result of a continued spell of hot
weather
combined with the necessity of quenching
his thirst with an augmented amount of
sack
and it actually died while handsome dick
with god knows what thoughts in his mind
was journeying northwards thus it came
about that he arrived at church peverell
just in time for his brother's funeral
it was with great propriety that he
attended the obsequies and returned to
spend a sympathetic day or two of
mourning with his widowed sister-in-law
who is but a faint-hearted dame little
fit to be mated with such hawks as these
on the second night of his stay he did
that which the peverells regret to this
day
he entered the room where the twins
slept with their nurse and quietly
strangled the latter as she slept
then he took the twins and put them into
the fire which warms the long gallery
the weather which up to the day of
joseph's death had been so hot
had changed suddenly to bitter cold and
the fire was heaped high with burning
logs and was exultant with flame
in the core of this conflagration he
struck out a cremation chamber
and into that he threw the two children
stamping them down with his riding boots
they could just walk but they could not
walk out of that ardent place
it is said that he laughed as he added
more logs
thus he became master of church peverell
the crime was never brought home to him
but he lived no longer than a year
and the enjoyment of his blood-stained
inheritance when he lay dying he made
his confession
to the priest who attended him but his
spirit struggled forth from its fleshly
coil
before absolution could be given him
on that very night there began in church
peverell the haunting which to this day
is but seldom spoken of by the family
and then only in low tones and with
serious mean
for only an hour or two after handsome
dick's death one of the servants passing
the door of the long gallery heard from
within peels of the loud laughter
so jovial and yet so sinister which he
had thought would never be heard in the
house again
in a moment of that cold courage which
is so nearly akin to mortal terror
he opened the door and entered expecting
to see he knew not what manifestation of
him who lay dead in the room below
instead he saw two little white robed
figures toddling towards him hand in
hand
across the moonlit floor the watchers in
the room below ran upstairs startled by
the crash of his fallen body
and found him lying in the grip of some
dread convulsion
just before morning he regained
consciousness and told his tale
then pointing with trembling and ash
grey finger towards the door
he screamed aloud and so fell back dead
during the next 50 years the strange and
terrible legend of the twin babies
became fixed and consolidated
their appearance luckily for those who
inhabit the house was exceedingly rare
and during these years they seemed to
have been seen four or five times only
on each occasion they appeared at night
between sunset and sunrise
always in the same long gallery and
always as two toddling children
scarcely able to walk and on each
occasion
the luckless individual who saw them
died either speedily or terribly
or with both speed and terror after the
accursed vision had appeared to him
sometimes he might live for a few months
he was lucky if he died as did the
servant who first saw them
in a few hours vastly more awful was the
fate of a certain mrs canning
who had the ill luck to see them in the
middle of the next century
or to be quite accurate in the year
1760.
by this time the hours and the place of
their appearance were well known
and as up till a year ago visitors were
warned not to go between sunset and
sunrise into the long gallery
but mrs canning a brilliantly clever and
beautiful woman
admirer also and friend of the notorious
skeptic m voltaire
willingly went and sat night after night
in spite of all protestations
in the haunted place for four evenings
she saw nothing
but on the fifth she had her will for
the door in the middle of the gallery
opened
and there came toddling towards her the
ill-omened innocent little pair
it seemed that even then she was not
frightened but she thought good
poor wretch to mock at them telling them
it was time for them to get back into
the fire
they gave no word and answer but turned
away from her crying and sobbing
immediately after they disappeared from
her vision and she rustled downstairs to
where the family and guests in the house
were waiting for her
with a triumphant announcement that she
has seen them both and must needs right
to m voltaire
saying that she had spoken to spirits
made manifest it would make him laugh
but when some months later the whole
news reached him
he did not laugh at all mrs canning was
one of the great beauties of her day
and in the year 1760 she was at the
height and zenith of her blossoming
the chief beauty if it is possible to
single out one point where all was so
exquisite
lay in the dazzling color and
incomparable brilliance of her
complexion
she was now just 30 years of age but in
spite of the excesses of her life
retained the snow and roses of girl hood
and she courted the bright light of day
which other women shunned
for it but showed to great advantage the
splendor of her skin
in consequence she was very considerably
dismayed one morning
about a fortnight after her strange
experience in the long gallery
to observe on her left cheek an inch or
two below her turquoise colored eyes
a little grayish patch of skin about as
big as a three-penny piece
it was in vain that she applied her
accustomed washes and unguents
vane too were the arts of her makeup and
of her medical advisor
for a week she kept herself secluded
murdering herself with solitude and
unaccustomed physics
and for a result at the end of the week
she had no amelioration to comfort
herself with
instead this woeful gray patch had
doubled itself in size
thereafter the nameless disease whatever
it was developed in new and terrible
ways
from the center of the discolored place
there sprouted forth little lichen-like
tendrils of greenish-gray
and another patch appeared on her lower
lip this too
soon vegetated and one morning on
opening her eyes to the horror of a new
day
she found that her vision was strangely
blurred she sprang to her looking glass
and what she saw caused her to shriek
aloud with horror
from under her upper eyelid a fresh
growth had sprung up mushroom-like in
the night
and its filaments extended downwards
screening the pupil of her eye
soon after her tongue and throat were
attacked the air passages became
obstructed
and death by suffocation was merciful
after such suffering
more terrible yet was the case of a
certain colonel blantire who fired at
the children with his revolver
what he went through is not to be
recorded here
it is this haunting then that the
peverells take quite seriously
and every guest on his arrival in the
house is told that the long gallery must
not be entered after nightfall on any
pretext whatever
by day however it is a delightful room
and intrinsically merits description
apart from the fact that the due
understanding of its geography
is necessary for the account that here
follows it is full 80 feet in length
and is lit by a row of six tall windows
looking over the gardens at the back of
the house
a door communicates with the landing at
the top of the main staircase
and about halfway down the gallery and
the wall facing the windows
is another door communicating with the
back staircase and servant's quarters
and thus the gallery forms a constant
place of passage for them
in going to the rooms on the first
landing it was through this door that
the baby figures came when they appeared
to mrs canning
and on several other occasions they have
been known to make their entry here
for the room out of which handsome dick
took them lies just beyond at the top of
the back stairs
further on again in the gallery is the
fireplace into which he thrusts them
and at the far end a large bow window
looks straight down the avenue
above this fireplace their hangs with
grim significance a portrait of handsome
dick
in the insolent beauty of early manhood
attributed to holbein
and a dozen other portraits of great
merit face the windows
during the day this is the most
frequented sitting room in the house
for its other visitors never appear
there then nor does it ever resound with
a harsh jovial laugh of handsome dick
which sometimes after dark has fallen is
heard by passersby on the landing
outside
but blanche does not grow bright-eyed
when she hears it she shuts her ears and
hastens to put a greater distance
between her
and the sound of that atrocious mirth
but during the day the long gallery is
frequented by many occupants and much
laughter and no wise sinister or
saturnine resounds there
when summer lies hot over the land those
occupants lounge in the deep window
seats
and when winter spreads his icy fingers
and blows shrilly between his frozen
palms
congregate round the fireplace at the
far end and perch and companies of
cheerful chatterers
upon sofa and chair and chair back and
floor
often have i sat there on long august
evenings up until dressing time
but never have i been there when anyone
has seemed disposed to linger over late
without hearing the warning it is close
on sunset shall we go
later on in the shorter autumn days they
often have tea laid there
and sometimes it has happened that even
while merriment was most uproarious
mrs peverell has suddenly looked out of
the window and said my dears it's
getting so late
let us finish our nonsense downstairs in
the hall
and then for a moment a curious hush
always falls on loquacious family and
guests alike
and as if some bad news had just been
known we all make our silent way out of
the place
but the spirits of the perils of the
living ones that is to say
are the most mercurial imaginable and
the blight which the thought of handsome
dick and his doings casts over them
passes away again with amazing rapidity
a typical party large young and
peculiarly cheerful
was staying at church peverell shortly
after christmas last year
and as usual on december 31st mrs
peverle was giving her annual new year's
eve ball
the house was quite full and she had
commandeered as well the greater part of
the peverell arms to provide sleeping
quarters for the overflow from the house
for some days past a black and windless
frost had stopped all hunting
but it is an ill windlessness that blows
no good if so mixed a metaphor may be
forgiven
and the lake below the house had for the
last day or two been covered with an
adequate and
admirable sheet of ice everyone in the
house had been occupied all the morning
of that day and performing swift and
violent maneuvers on the elusive surface
and as soon as lunch was over we all
with one exception hurried out again
this one exception was madge dalrymple
who had had the misfortune to fall
rather badly earlier in the day
but hoped by resting her injured knee
instead of joining the skaters again
to be able to dance that evening the
hope it is true was the most sanguine
sort
for she could but hobble ignobly back to
the house but with the breezy optimism
which characterizes the peverels
she is blanche's first cousin she
remarked that it would be but tepid
enjoyment that she could in her present
state derive from further skating
and thus she sacrificed little but might
gain much
accordingly after a rapid cup of coffee
which was served in the long gallery
we left madge comfortably reclined on
the big sofa at right angles to the
fireplace
with an attractive book to beguile the
tedium till t
being of the family she knew all about
handsome dick and the babies
and the fate of mrs canning and colonel
blantire but as we went out i heard
blanche say to her
don't run it too fine dear and madge had
replied
no i'll go away well before sunset and
so we left her alone
in the long gallery madge read her
attractive book for some minute
but failing to get absorbed in it put it
down and limped across to the window
though it was still but a little after
two it was but a dim and uncertain light
that entered
for the crystal and brightness of the
morning had given place to a veiled
obscurity
produced by flocks of thick clouds which
were coming sluggishly up from the
northeast
already the whole sky was overcast with
them and occasionally a few
snowflakes fluttered waveringly down
past the long windows
from the darkness and bitter cold of the
afternoon it seemed to her that there
was like to be a heavy snowfall before
long
and these outward signs were echoed
inwardly in her by that muffled
drowsiness
of the brain which to those who are
sensitive to the pressures and lightness
of weather pretend storm
madge was peculiarly the prey of such
external influences
to her a brisk morning gave an ineffable
brightness and briskness of spirit
and correspondingly the approach of
heavy weather produced a somnolence and
sensation
that both drowsed and depressed her it
was in such mood as this that she limped
back again to the sofa beside the log
fire
the whole house was comfortably heated
by water pipes and though the fire of
logs and pete
an adorable mixture had been allowed to
burn low the room was very warm
oddly she watched the dwindling flames
not opening her book again
but lying on the sofa with face towards
the fireplace
intending drowsily and not immediately
to go to her own room and spend the
hours
until the return of the skaters made
gaiety in the house again
in writing one or two neglected letters
still drowsily she began thinking over
what she had to communicate
one letter several days overdue should
go to her mother who was immensely
interested in the psychical affairs of
the family
she would tell her how master anthony
had been prodigiously active on the
staircase a night or two ago
and how the blue lady regardless of the
severity of the weather
had been seen by mrs peverell that
morning strolling about
it was rather interesting the blue lady
had gone down the laurel walk
and had been seen by her to enter the
stables where at the moment freddy
peverell was inspecting the frostbound
hunters
identically then a sudden panic had
spread through the stables
and the horses had winnied and kicked
and shied and sweated
of the fatal twins nothing had been seen
for many years past
but as her mother knew the peverels
never used the long gallery after dark
then for a moment she sat up remembering
that she was in the long gallery now
but it was still but a little after half
past two and if she went to her room in
half an hour
she would have ample time to write this
and another letter before tea
till then she would read her book but
she found she had left it on the
windowsill
and it seemed scarcely worthwhile to get
it she felt exceedingly drowsy
the sofa where she lay had been lightly
recovered in a grayish green shade of
velvet
somewhat the color of lichen it was a
very thick
soft texture and she luxuriously
stretched her arms out
one on each side of her body and pressed
her fingers into the nap
how horrible that story of mrs canning
was the growth on her face was the color
of lykan
and then without further transition or
blurring of thought madge
fell asleep she dreamed
she dreamed that she awoke and found
herself exactly where she had gone to
sleep
and in exactly the same attitude the
flames from the logs had burned up again
and leaped on the walls fitfully
illuminating the picture of handsome
dick above the fireplace
in her dream she knew exactly what she
had done today and for what reason she
was lying here now
instead of being out with the rest of
the skaters she remembered also
still dreaming that she was going to
write a letter or two before tea
and prepared to get up in order to go to
her room
as she half rose she caught sight of her
own arms lying out on each side of her
on the gray velvet sofa
but she could not see where her hands
ended and where the gray velvet began
her fingers seemed to have melted into
the stuff
she could see her wrists quite clearly
and a blue vein on the backs of her
hands
and here and there a knuckle then in her
dream she remembered
the last thought which had been in her
mind before she fell asleep
namely the growth of the lycan-colored
vegetation on the face and the eyes and
the throat of mrs canning
at that thought the strangling terror of
real nightmare began
she knew that she was being transformed
into this gray stuff
and she was absolutely unable to move
soon the grey would spread up her arms
and over her feet
when they came in from skating they
would find here nothing but a huge
misshapen cushion of lichen-colored
velvet
and that would be she the horror grew
more acute
and then by a violent effort she shook
herself free of the clutches of this
very evil dream
and she awoke for a minute or two she
lay there
conscious only of the tremendous relief
at finding herself awake
she felt again with her fingers the
pleasant touch of the velvet and drew
them backwards and forwards
assuring herself that she was not as her
dream had suggested
melting into grayness and softness but
she was still
in spite of the violence of her
awakening very sleepy
and lay there till looking down she was
aware that she could not see her hands
at all
it was very nearly dark at that moment a
sudden flicker of flame
came from the dying fire and a flare of
burning gas from the peat flooded the
room
the portrait of handsome dick looked
evilly down on her and her hands were
visible again
and then a panic worse than the panic of
her dream seized her
daylight had altogether faded and she
knew that she was alone
in the dark in the terrible gallery this
panic was of the nature of nightmare for
she felt unable to move for terror
but it was worse than nightmare because
she knew she was awake
and then the full cause of this frozen
fear dawned on her she knew with the
certainty of absolute conviction
that she was about to see the twin
babies
she felt a sudden moisture breakout on
her face and within her mouth her tongue
and throat went suddenly dry
and she felt her tongue great along the
inner surface of her teeth
all power of movement had slipped from
her limbs leaving them dead and inert
and she stared with wide eyes into the
blackness the spurt of flame
from the peat had burned itself out
again and darkness encompassed her
then on the wall opposite her facing the
windows there grew a faint light of
dusky crimson
for a moment she thought it but heralded
the approach of the awful vision
then hope revived in her heart and she
remembered that thick clouds had
overcast the sky before she went to
sleep
and guessed that this light came from
the sun not yet quite sunk and set
this sudden revival of hope gave her the
necessary stimulus
and she sprang off the sofa where she
lay she looked out of the window and saw
the dull glow on the horizon
but before she could take a step forward
it was obscured again
a tiny sparkle of light came from the
hearth which did no more than illuminate
the tiles of the fireplace
and snow falling heavily tapped at the
window panes
there was neither light nor sound except
these
but the courage that had come to her
giving her the power of movement
had not quite deserted her and she began
feeling her way down the gallery
and then she found that she was lost she
stumbled against a chair
and recovering herself stumbled against
another then a table barred her way
and turning swiftly aside she found
herself up against the back of a sofa
once more she turned and saw the dim
gleam of the fire light on the side
opposite to that on which she expected
it in her blind groping she must have
reversed her direction
but which way was she to go now she
seemed blocked in by furniture
and all the time insistent and imminent
was the fact that the two innocent
terrible ghosts were about to appear to
her
then she began to pray lighten our
darkness o lord
she said to herself but she could not
remember how the prayer continued and
she had sore need of it
there was something about the perils of
the night all this time she felt about
with her groping fluttering hands
the fire glimmer which should have been
on her left was on her right again
therefore she must turn herself round
again light in our darkness she
whispered and then aloud she repeated
lighten our darkness she stumbled up
against a screen and could not remember
the existence of any such screen
hastily she felt beside it with blind
hands and touched something soft and
velvety
was it the sofa on which she had lain if
so where was the head of it
it had a head and a back and feet it was
like a person
all covered with grey lychen then she
lost her head completely
all that remained to her was to pray she
was lost
lost in this awful place where no one
came in the dark
except the babies that cried and she
heard her voice rising from whisper to
speech
and speech to scream she shrieked out
the holy words
she yelled them as if blaspheming as she
groped among tables and chairs
and the pleasant things of ordinary life
which had become so terrible
then came a sudden and an awful answer
to her screamed prayer
once more a pocket of inflammable gas
and the peed on the hearth
was reached by the smoldering embers and
the rooms started into light
she saw the evil eyes of handsome dick
she saw the little ghostly snowflakes
falling thickly outside
and she saw where she was just opposite
the door through which the terrible
twins made their entrance
then the flame went out again and left
her in blackness once more
but she had gained something for she had
her geography now
the center of the room was bare of
furniture and one swift dart would take
her to the door of the landing above the
main staircase and into safety
in that gleam she had been able to see
the handle of the door bright brassed
luminous like a star she would go
straight for it
it was but a matter of a few seconds now
she took a long breath
partly of relief partly to satisfy the
demands of her galloping heart
but the breath was only half taken when
she was stricken once more into the
immobility of nightmare
there came a little whisper it was no
more than that from the door opposite
which she stood
and through which the twin babies
entered it was not quite dark outside it
for she could see that the door was
opening and there stood in the opening
two little white figures
side by side they came towards her
slowly
shufflingly she could not see face or
form at all distinctly
but the two little white figures were
advancing
she knew them to be the ghosts of terror
innocent of the awful doom they were
bound to bring
even as she was innocent with the
inconceivable rapidity of thought
she made up her mind what to do she had
not hurt them or laughed at them
and they they were but babies when the
wicked and bloody deed had sent them to
their burning death
surely the spirits of these children
would not be inaccessible to the cry of
one who was of the same blood as they
who had committed no fault that merited
the doom they brought
if she entreated them they might have
mercy they might forbear to bring the
curse on her
they might allow her to pass out of the
place without blight without the
sentence of death
or the shadow of things worse than death
upon her
it was but for the space of a moment
that she hesitated then she sank down on
her knees
and stretched out her hands towards them
oh my dears she said
i only fell asleep i've done no more
wrong than that
she paused a moment and her tender
girl's heart thought no more of herself
but only of them those little innocent
spirits on whom so awful a doom was laid
that they should bring death where other
children bring laughter and doom for
delight
but all those who had seen them before
had dreaded and feared them
or had mocked at them then as the
enlightenment of pity dawned on her
her fear fell from her like the wrinkled
sheath that holds the sweet-folded buds
of spring
dears i am so sorry for you she said it
is not your fault that you must bring me
what you must bring
but i am not afraid any longer i am only
sorry for you
god bless you you poor darlings she
raised her head and looked at them
though it was so dark she could now see
their faces though all was dim and
wavering
like the light of pale flames shaken by
a draft
but the faces were not miserable or
fierce they smiled at her with shy
little baby smiles
and as she looked they grew faint fading
slowly away like wreaths of vapor and
frosty air
madge did not at once move when they had
vanished for instead of fear that was
wrapped around her a wonderful sense of
peace
so happy and serene that she would not
willingly stir and so perhaps disturb it
but before long she got up and feeling
her way but without any sense of
nightmare pressing her on
or frenzy of fear to spur her she went
out of the long gallery
to find blanche just coming upstairs
whistling and swinging her skates
how's the leg dear she asked you're not
limping anymore
till that moment madge had not thought
of it i think it must be all right she
said
i had forgotten it anyhow blanche dear
you won't be frightened for me will you
but
but i've seen the twins for a moment
blanche's face whitened with terror
what she said in a whisper yes i saw
them just now
but they were kind they smiled at me and
i was so sorry for them
and somehow i'm sure i have nothing to
fear
it seems that madge was right for
nothing has come to touch her
something her attitude to them we must
suppose her pity her sympathy
touched and dissolved and annihilated
the curse
indeed i was at church peverell only
last week arriving there after dark
just as i passed the gallery door
blanche came out
ah there you are she said i've just been
seeing the twins
they looked too sweet and stopped nearly
10 minutes
let us have tea at once
you